there's an article rocketing around the
internet it was from a new york magazine
the cover of new york magazine featured
a quote unquote trans man meaning a
biological woman who believes that she
is a man
whose new name is gabrielle mack okay
gabrielle or gabriel mack the original
name of this human was in fact mack
mcclellan but then this woman decided
that she is in fact some sort of trans
man and therefore had to appear on the
cover
of new york magazine
in her underwear i say her because i
only use biological pronouns on this
show
in her underwear after having a breast
removal surgery and after having had a
surgery to essentially carve a fake
penis out of her leg and then attach it
to herself
this is what our society has become in
one photo this is what our society has
become when radical subjectivism rules
the roost and reality is forced to bow
before the altar of radical subjectivism
what you end up with is effectively
bodily mutilation there's no way to look
at this photo and not see a form of
bodily mutilation this is literally a
person who has had flesh from her leg
removed in order to carve out a fake
genitalia
and then
say that she has now become a man by the
way this person also says that she has
retained her original female
genitals in terms of her vagina so she
still has a biological vagina and now
has added on a
fake penis through a phalloplasty and i
say fake penis because this is not a
naturally grown thing shall we say it is
it is carved out of human flesh okay now
i don't mean to be
extremely graphic but that's the entire
point of the article
the entire point of the article from new
york magazine is to be as extremely
graphic as possible which is why the
photo is on the cover of new york
magazine that's why you have extremely
graphic photos of what the leg looks
like after the removal of the flesh
and you are supposed to just mirror the
perspective of the article you're
supposed to mirror the idea that this
person used to be a woman and is now a
man
so over the weekend i was rereading 1984
and the truth is that 1984 while it is a
a morality play
about the stalinesque soviet regime
in reality it's a little bit deeper than
that what it really is is about how you
control minds it's about thought crime
and doublethink and mind control it's
how people's minds are captured and then
used against them
and this is what we are in the midst of
culturally in the united states you are
not allowed the few centimeters in your
brain that allow you a level of thought
freedom
that would be to commit a thought crime
if you right now are thinking that this
person
obviously suffers from a mental disorder
and i will bring you more information
about this person just a moment that
this person obviously suffers from a
mental disorder and that
and that brutal surgeries are very
unlikely
to represent a solution to that mental
disorder
if you think that then this means that
you are a vicious terrible person you
are transphobic you are heteronormative
you're cishet right all of this nonsense
so orwell writes in 1984 and this is
really the essence of 1984 it says
double think lies at the very heart of
the regime since the essential act of
the party is to use conscious deception
while retaining the firmness of purpose
that goes with complete honesty to tell
deliberate lies while genuinely
believing in them to forget any fact
that has become inconvenient and then
when it becomes necessary again to draw
it back from oblivion for just so long
as it is needed to deny the existence of
objective reality and all the while to
take account of the reality which ones
and eyes all this is indispensably
necessary
this is correct
this is the the culture that we have now
been creating for ourselves
or while writing about this in the
context of soviet mind control
essentially he says
in the end the party would announce that
two in two made five and you would have
to believe it it was inevitable that
they should make that claim sooner or
later the logic of their position
demanded it not merely the validity of
experience but the very existence of
external reality was tacitly denied by
their philosophy the heresy of heresies
was common sense and what was terrifying
was not that they would kill you for
thinking otherwise but that they might
be right for after all how do we know
that two and two make four or that the
force of gravity works or that the past
is unchangeable if both the past and the
external world exist only in the mind
and if the mind itself is controllable
what then
in order to reach utopia you wonder why
this is part of a left-wing agenda
because really this what does this have
to do with redistribution of income per
se what does this have to do with the
structures of the economy what does this
have to do even with fairness and equity
what does it have to do with any of this
stuff what do bizarre claims about the
nature of gender that are completely
anti-biological and anti-common sense
what does that have to do with any of
this and the answer is it all lies in
the root belief that man is entirely
malleable and that reality exists
entirely in the mind so if we just shift
how we think about reality a man can be
a woman a woman can be a man
all human beings can be remolded and
shaped into utopian forms of themselves
widgets that we can play with from the
top down to create a better society
that is how this particularly bizarre
and radical perspective on gender fits
into the broader left-wing rubric
because once you have subjected yourself
to
relentless
subjectivism once you have decided that
radical subjectivism is the truth about
life that reality does not exist out
here there's no such thing as reality
there are no such things as rules rules
of biology do not exist rules of physics
do not exist rules of history do not
nothing exists
the only thing that exists is in your
mind
and that's the only thing that matters
because it grants you a sense of
authenticity once you believe that you
can accomplish anything in this view
that is why this is important
not because this particular person this
particular person doing what this person
wishes to do with their life i disagree
with the decisions i don't think this is
going to alleviate anything i think the
surgeons who perform these sorts of
surgeries are committing a grave sin
against humanity frankly but
adults are adults in a free country
okay that said
the the baseline notion that the rest of
society has to accept as truth something
that is obviously a lie is
extraordinarily dangerous and it ties
into a broader belief system that says
that lies can become the truth so long
as those lies are convenient and
necessary for the pursuit of utopia
we'll get some more on this matter in
just one second first it's time for you
to get the respect you so richly deserve
the established titles this is your
opportunity to earn the title of lord or
lady and gain the respect you deserve
all you need is one square foot plot of
land in scotland established titles is a
project based on a historic scottish
custom where landowners are referred to
as lairds or lores and ladies in english
in your title pack you will receive at
least one square foot of dedicated land
on a private estate and an official
certificate with a crest your
certificate will include a unique plot
number with which you can see the exact
location of your land and as we are
approaching christmas i should also
mention this is a great last minute gift
like the best last minute gift the way
to surprise your loved ones from
girlfriends boyfriends to family you
could even get a couple pack for you and
your partner where you can get adjoining
plots of land with the certificate you
can even officially change your name to
lord or lady and get it put on your
credit card or on your plane tickets or
pretty much anything else don't just
pick your pronouns become an actual lord
or lady today with established titles
they're having a great limited time sale
so go to establishtitles.com
ben shapiro to save 10 off today
remember to use the discount code ben
shapiro or just click the link below
that's
establishedtitles.com ben shapiro or
just click on that link below before we
get to the story the details of the
story i just want to point out that the
typical left-wing response to anybody
even commenting on this is why do you
care
i care because you put this on the cover
of a major national magazine that's why
i care because you made this a national
story a person making what i believe to
be a bad decision for themselves is not
a national news story you made it a
national news story and the reason you
did so is specifically so that when we
comment on it when we notice that you
are fighting against common sense and
frankly common decency
when we notice that you are lying to
people about the malleability of human
sex
when we notice that you call us bigots
and you say why are you even noticing
why why do you notice why do you notice
we're noticing because you have made
this the front line of the culture war
and you want to dictate this to my
children you want to tell my kids that
your view of gender and sex is the real
view of gender and sex and you want to
call anybody who disagrees a bigot
in other words this is bait
but if you don't take debate then they
win because if you don't take debate
then the assumption is that what they
are saying has some relation to reality
or decency and it has no relation to
either
and so honestly i feel terrible for this
human being the reason i feel terrible
for this human being is this person
obviously has serious problems
here is a story from july 5th 2011
journalists stages her own rape to cure
trauma of witnessing sex attack on women
in haiti
for journalist mac mcclelland you'll
notice that gabriel mack and mack
mcclelland are the same human despite
the fact that she had seen the impact of
sexual violence all around the globe
having reported from the congo in burma
this incident was more than she could
take
according to abc she became
progressively enveloped in the classic
symptoms of post-traumatic stress
avoidance of feelings flashbacks
recurrent thoughts that triggered crying
spells she couldn't get out of bed in
the morning and had nightmares and
daymares about rape
the 31 year old went to see a therapist
in her home of san francisco and despite
getting treatment for ptsd she told her
therapist all she wanted to do was have
incredibly violent sex
her therapist suggested it was a good
idea and told her to find someone who
she trusted enough to do it
miss mcclellan believed it was this
staged violent rape with a close friend
that cured her
she even wrote an article about it for
the online magazine good
in it she explains how her sexual
partner mercilessly pinned her beat her
about the head and brutally violated her
she wrote about the rape i did not enjoy
it in a way a person getting screwed
normally would but as it became clear
that i could endure it i started to take
deeper breaths and my mind stayed there
stayed present even when it became
painful even when he smothered me with a
pillow not to asphyxiate me but so that
he didn't break my jaw when he drew his
elbow back and slammed his fist into my
face two three four times my body felt
devastated but relieved i lost but
survived after he climbed off me he
gathered me up in his arms i broke into
a thousand pieces on his chest sobbing
so hard my rips felt like my ribs felt
like they were coming loose she told abc
i was not crazy it was a way for me to
deal in a sort of simulated but
controlled situation it was still awful
and the body doesn't understand when
it's in a fight
so this is a person who was not raped
had ptsd
from not
her rape but from witnessing another
person's response to a rape
and had a friend simulate rape in which
she was beaten
so this is the person that we are
talking about
does this sound like a mentally ordered
person to you a well-ordered person to
you
and this is not to rip on people who
have mental disorders there are people
in my family with mental disorders my
grandfather i've talked about it openly
it was a manic depressive who was
suicidal from time to time
okay so this is not to mock the mentally
disordered this is to point out that
when a society treats mental disorders
as perfectly healthy behavior you
incentivize mental disorders and by the
way you don't heal anybody you don't
make anybody better
in fact in many cases you make them
worse when you humor mental disorder
you are not making the mental disorder
better
my grandfather who was manic depressive
as i mentioned
he had the experience of believing that
the radio was talking to him telling him
to kill himself
and for years my grandmother who just
passed away
my grandmother
would lie in bed and tie her foot to his
because she knew that if he got up in
the middle of the night he might try to
kill himself with a razor okay that is
what mental disorders are
to pretend that the radio actually was
talking to him and we just needed to
humor that would have been cruelty it
wasn't until he got on lithium decades
later that he actually began to live a
normal life
a treating people who are mentally
disordered as though that is a form of
mental order and that it's only society
that has done something wrong is cruel
and nasty
and then to dictate to the rest of the
world that the rest of the world is
supposed to mirror this perspective is
insane and it promotes insanity
okay and this brings us to the new york
magazine cover piece my penis myself i
didn't need a penis to be a man but i
needed one to be me
well actually it turns out you're not a
man it turns out you're a biological
woman with
as evidenced by your own coverage of the
issues
some problems
and i feel honest to god i feel terrible
for this person but to pretend that this
person is just a mentally healthy man is
ridiculous on every possible level that
is possible for it makes a mockery of
the word ridiculous to suggest this is
ridiculous okay so this brings us to the
actual cover story from new york
magazine
okay
on the day i heard that my penis would
be huge i sobbed
in the car outside the doctor's office
afterward i bent my torso in half and
bald my face against the dashboard my
boyfriend petting my back to console me
but confused isn't it good news that
they can do it like at all and obviously
yes it was growing up without one i
thought or maybe convinced myself that
mine would grow in later to the extent
that when i see a woman in tight pants i
still often instinctively think where is
her penis but my period at 12 aptly
agonizingly bled to death that
increasingly implausible dream of
reconciling with life with god that he
wouldn't make me like this and leave me
like this forever so the news 28 years
later that the agony was going to be
over abundantly over was a bit much to
take in phalloplasty in general it was
clear it was hard for people to accept
well i will love you no matter what
sweetie a cis female best friend of mine
said when i told her i was transitioning
years before as long as you don't get a
dick one flatly demanded don't get a
dick it was another trans masculine
person i used to know said disgusting
insane to want or to have a surgeon make
a sensate phallus out of your arm or leg
or somewhere and frankenstitch it to
your body to go so far out of your way
to opt into a tool perhaps the tool of
so much suffering i love that there are
people who are so left-wing that the
presence
of
a penis is
itself
somehow an act of violence okay that
penis dr balbach safa one of the
microsurgeons said when he came by to
see me after to see us looks perfect
he was mostly talking about the blood
flow he did not mean that with its fresh
stitches and a round bloody hole at the
top where the skin would eventually
close together it would look like any
other penis at the spa but also it was a
lovely shape
okay so are we supposed to believe that
this makes you a man
is that the idea that this makes so
according to this person this didn't
make them a man the feeling made them a
man but they needed the penis in order
to feel complete
and then this needed to be put on the
cover of new york magazine
to promote the idea that this is
a reflection of biological reality that
this person is a man now
understand this article is not about
gabriel mack and this person's
experiences in life this article is
about you
because the goal is to make you believe
make you believe that two and two are
five
that is the goal and if you refuse to
believe two and two or five this makes
you a bigot this makes you a bad person
this means you'll be socially ostracized
this means that common sense must go by
the wayside the demand is not
for quote unquote tolerance the demand
is for acceptance and celebration
and belief more than anything else
belief
radical subjectivism is not the way any
functional society can work
because radical subjectivism eventually
and this is the point in 1984 radical
subjectivism eventually will be
subjugated in favor of a top-down
version of reality that somebody wants
to impose and that top-down version of
reality that somebody wants to impose
particularly the folks in the media is a
version of reality
that is absolutely contrary to actual
biological
physical reality
but allows for the possibility of innate
malleability of humanity in any
direction that they choose that's the
goal
what this is really about more than
anything else is getting you
again to believe two and two or five
that's what this is about
we're in a battle for the culture and
for our values like and subscribe to
help keep our videos on the front line
of the fight and top of your feed